Виправна колонія у Липецьку
за 400 кілометрів від Москви.
Переповнена, як майже всі російські в’язниці.
Правозахисники скаржаться,
що забагато росіян кидають за ґрати.
А це породжує характерну для країни „тюремну культуру",
яка відрізняється своєю жорстокістю
та подібністю до ГУЛАГів часів Сталіна.
Багато з ув'язнених є жертвами
корумпованого і непрофесійного правосуддя,
критикує систему Ольга Романова
з московського фонду„Русь, що сидить“.
Ця організація опікується жертвами російського судового свавілля.
Русь сидить, сидить щільно.
Загальноприйнятою стала приказка:
третина сидить не за те,
третина - ні за що, а ще третина - по заслузі.
Ці четверо росіян - колишні в’язні,
які з різних причин і в різний час постали
перед судом і були засуджені.
Тепер вони відкрито розповідають про своє перебування за ґратами.
Фізично ламають твою особистість,
пригнічують твій взагалі дух.
Тебе як особистість пригнічують силою.
Побачення відбуваються раз на 4 місяці,
раз на 5 місяців. Що таке два дні?
Просто ти не можеш обійняти,
не можеш поцілувати близьку людину.
Найжахливіше те, що за мій період перебування
там померло приблизно 18 людей.
Раз на два місяці помирала одна людина.
І я бачив, що це відбувалася через певну системну помилку.
Системи з правоохоронної і з судової
перетворилися на статистичні органи,
які женуться за статистикою,
але аж ніяк не прагнуть правосуддя.
Держава робить з людей злочинців через гроші,
скаржаться критики.
Якщо у відділку поліції в січні посадили 100 людей,
то у лютому ніяк не може бути 90.
Не виконуєте план, шановні громадяни. А 110 – добре.
Тюрма фінансується відповідно до кількості людей.
Чим більше осіб сидить,
тим більший бюджет у тюремного відомства,
відповідно тим більший бюджет у суддів,
тим більший бюджет у прокурорів, тим більший бюджет у слідчих.
Звичайно ж, довкола вороги, довкола злочинність.
Гроші, гроші, гроші.
Про реформу системи правосуддя
неодноразово говорили й в Кремлі.
Утім, ця тюремна "держава в державі"
досі працює за старими правилами.